good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you are very welcome to join us
on the breakfast show here on sky news
this wednesday morning a bigger squeeze
is coming in the cost of living crisis
that's the new warning this morning for
tens of thousands of us what's the
government going to do about it we'll
ask the levelling up secretary michael
gove shortly as his boss hints help is
coming in the near future and his
colleague the chancellor hints
it isn't
plus the queen's speech barely alluded
to the northern ireland protocol as the
row on whether or not to scrap it rages
so what will happen with that we'll get
the views of labour's justice secretary
steve reid plus the smp westminster
leader ian blackford and the leader of
the lib dems that's sir ed davey it's
wednesday the 11th of may
no emergency budget treasury slapped
down after the prime minister hints that
help for the cost of living crisis could
be announced in days
new figures reveal that 1.5 million
british households could be heading for
a big bills
i'm here at a car boot sale to find out
how they're coping
[Music]
shining a light in the darkness the
photos that tell the story of the
ukrainian soldiers suffering beneath the
besieged steelworks in mariopon
boris johnson travels to sweden and
finland today ahead of a crucial
decision by both countries on joining
nato a move that would further provoke
russia
flat out stupid elon musk the
billionaire set to buy twitter promises
to let trump back on the platform
criticizing the fact that he was banned
in the first place
banning trump from twitter didn't end
trump's voice
it will amplify it
among the rights and this is why it is
morally wrong and flat-out stupid
sticking the boot in colleen rooney and
rebecca vardy face off in the wagatha
christie trial we'll bring you the
latest evidence live from court
not sustainable a warning about china's
kovid zero strategy from the man at the
top of the world health organization
the multi-multi
multi-million pound jackpot winner of
the euro millions revealed to be a
ticket bought in
the uk
not me is it otherwise i wouldn't be sat
here also this morning for you wherever
you're watching us from australia to
africa
thrown into the limelight as prince
charles fills in for the queen at the
state opening of parliament we'll ask
the historian sir anthony selden for his
views on the future of the monarchy
[Applause]
[Music]
last wouldn't bet against some would you
singing for ukraine the act
uh thought to uh be in the grand final
of the eurovision song contest we'll be
uh speaking to the politics of the
contest that's at 9 45.
[Music]
good morning we start with a warning
that things could be about to get
tougher for tens of thousands of us the
prime minister hinted yesterday that
more help could be on the way in the
near future for those struggling to make
ends meet
but soon after the treasury slapped down
that announcement telling sky news there
will be no emergency budget the leveling
up secretary michael gove will be on the
programme in just a moment first though
it comes as a multiple reports this
morning warn of the pressures facing uk
households
the national institute of economic and
social research says britain is on
course to enter the recession this year
with the think tank estimating one and a
half million households will soon
struggle with food and energy bills
meanwhile a survey by the consultancy
britain thinks found the cost of living
was now the dominant concern for uk
households 90 percent worried about the
effects of rising prices
and a separate study by shaw brook bank
showed that almost one in five were
already losing sleep over the issue
we are staring down the barrel of
something we haven't seen in decades
a stagflation crisis
it is a truly shocking legacy of this
government it should humble those on the
benches opposite a government of the
moment would use the great powers that
it has to tackle this head-on
bring forward an emergency budget we
will continue to use all our ingenuity
and compassion for as long as it takes
and my right home will offend the
chancellor and i will be saying more
about this in the days to come the cost
of living crisis is making life
difficult for many across the country we
have rising inflation the need to
restore public finances and as we level
up across the country we should ensure
that we're a government that doesn't
work just work for certain parts of a
country but a government that truly
works for everyone this should have been
a cost of living queen speech and there
was a hint in the prime minister's
speech i don't know if you caught it he
said that there was going to be some
measures brought forward by himself and
the chance in the next few days
yet the treasury are saying they have no
idea what the prime minister is
referring to
well the leveling up secretary michael
hove uh michael ho forgive me it's too
early in the morning michael gove of
course is with us here in the studio
thank you for joining us on the program
queen's speech boris johnson says he
can't shield everyone from the cost of
living crisis is what he said so where
does he put that shield
well we try to protect those who are
most vulnerable um we've already taken
steps for example by reducing council
tax for people who are in particular
cancer tax bands who tend to be at the
at the lower end of the income spectrum
but we also keep under review a range of
things that we can do both short term
and long term to help people so for
example in the queen's speech yesterday
there are steps that we're taking to
protect people who are renting both
those in the private rented sector and
those who are also in social homes in
order to ensure that we can have
security for them as well
dominic is on the program later on he's
a single dad he's on universal credit
and he says he's struggling to feed his
family and top up the pre-pay gas meter
will he fall within the uh shield well
we'll do everything that we can and
there are individual cases that i know
of as a member of parliament um
trying to represent my constituents
effectively with individuals who are in
similar circumstances to dominic who
face very difficult choices and that's
why in government last night the prime
minister convened a meeting of um most
of the cabinet uh everyone who has a
responsibility that bears on cost of
living to make sure that we were all
doing everything that we could to review
every policy disposal every policy lever
at our disposal in order to ensure that
we can help people like dominic and
others so the queen's speech yesterday
had a package of measures many of which
will help but it's also the case that we
don't just rest there we are uh always
uh in every way looking to see what we
can do to help citizens well let's talk
energy bills as a specific because
that's what dominic is talking about
later on i just saw an interview with
you back from 2016 before brexit and you
said that um after brexit we would cut
vat on fuel bills well after brexit we
could cut v80 on fuel you said you would
well at the time um i wasn't the energy
secretary at the time i said that i
remember the interview very well that
this was uh one of the things that we
could do outside the european union that
we could not do inside the european
union well what we've chosen to do is to
target the help on the very poorest
cutting vht on fuel bills would mean
that the um could help everybody who
pays a fuel bill including the duke of
devonshire um i've got nothing against
the duke but my view is that uh if
you've got a spare extra pound it
shouldn't go to dukes it should go to
people like dominic why did you
highlight it as a case back in 2016
because it was one of the freedoms that
brexit could bring us and there are
other brexit freedoms
in the queen's speech which will enable
us to both reduce the cost of living
pressures but also to grow the economy
because ultimately for dominic for you
for me the answer to economic pressures
now and in the future is a growing
economy so outside the european union
for example
we can take steps to make sure that our
farming and our agriculture and our
scientific sector uh can produce more
and can produce more cheaply but why
those bills are in the queensland sure
but why say uh as a result of uh leaving
the european union we could cut v80 on
fuel if you didn't think it was a good
idea um i thought it was a good idea it
is a good idea but not the priority when
you have a cost of living challenge of
the one that we do at the moment the
most important thing to do is to target
help on those people who are in relative
terms poorer and so they they you know i
want to cut all taxes all the time
everywhere but at the moment we have
that are we well we have to prioritize
um i should say that in the last spring
statement in the last spring statement
again
uh rishi showed that when it came to
allocating money his priority would
always be to help the poorest the
changes to universal credit um that uh
uh he has introduced with therese coffee
the working pension secretary have been
designed to help the poorest and vat on
fuel as i say
all tax cuts great but tax cuts that
help dukes as much as they help others
not necessarily the best at this time
okay so given that you mentioned the
treasury we heard from the prime
minister yesterday saying he will
say more in the days to come on how to
help people with the cost of living and
then almost immediately the treasury is
saying there'll be no emergency budget
and we'll set out the budget timetable
in the usual way so who's right is it is
there going to be an emergency budget or
not um uh they're both right and no
there won't be an emergency budget okay
explain that to me i will um the the key
thing is um it's sometimes the case
would never happen with sky it's
sometimes the case the words from a
prime minister or a minister are
over-interpreted so the prime minister
is right we will be saying more and
doing more in order to help people with
the cost of living a challenge that we
face at the moment but that doesn't
amount to an emergency budget it is part
of the work of government so last night
uh the prime minister convened a group
of ministers we'd all done work on some
of the things that we could do to help
uh those those policy initiatives
those policy initiatives will be
announced
by individual departments in due course
as they're worked up but that is part of
the uh the process for a government that
is always and everywhere thinking about
how we can help and how we can provide
support both short term and long term
the queen's speech yesterday it contains
legislation those laws will take a
little bit of time to pass but once
they're passed then they give government
the the big leave is necessary to
generate economic growth in the meantime
we look to see what we can do
more quickly to help but none of that
amounts to an emergency
so therefore both uh the prime minister
and the treasury were right one or two
people who were inclined to
over-interpret uh have now had the
chance to
correct the record or maybe the prime
minister misspoke not that he ever does
that he never does never does that um
leveling up um as your brief of course
hughes talked about tackling the
astronomical profits of property
developers yeah um what about the
astronomical profits of oil companies
well we look at all uh economic activity
and we make a judgment about what we can
do in order to help the consumer and to
help them looking at the astronomical
profits of oil companies
no i'm i'm looking specifically at the
uh the property sector and making sure
that uh companies
to be fair uh which have done well out
of government funding in the past um are
play their part in making sure first of
all that they uh help us to resolve the
the building safety issue the cladding
issue that uh the granville fire so
tragically brought to light and also
that we work with them in order to make
sure that more people have access to
high quality beautiful affordable homes
so um you know my my job in my
particular role at the moment is to
work with
those building companies and also to
work with local authorities to get the
right homes in the right places at the
right price so you've got your eye on
their astronomical profits but not on
the astronomical profits of energy
companies well as i say the the position
with uh energy uh was outlined in the uh
uh energy strategy that the prime
minister put forward uh uh just a few
weeks ago in which we outlined a path
towards uh energy security for the long
term um and making sure that we can have
uh access to a dependable supply of lots
of different types of energy that is the
right thing to do um and as has been
pointed out uh if you have the wrong
astronomical profits of the oil industry
well if you have the wrong sort of tax
applied
at the wrong time and in the wrong way
you can actually lead to companies not
investing for the long term said they
said nonsense we'll continue on with our
investment whether there's a winful tax
or not well you'll find many other
people not just in the oil and gas
sector but many other people who are
observing the the picture when it comes
to energy overall who would make the
point very eloquently that if you have a
tax that is introduced uh
as i say at the wrong time and in the
wrong way that will deter the investment
we need in order to ensure that we have
oil and gas in the north sea okay for
the long term so i was in aberdeen my
hometown
one of the things that people said to me
there is
if we're going to have a transition
towards net zero yeah oil and gas has to
be part of that yeah we need investment
we won't get that investment if we have
the wrong sort of tax applied now okay
we've uh i'd love to press you on that
more but we've not got time because i
want to talk to you about the northern
ireland protocol of course what's the
plan
well we want to make sure that we have a
situation in northern ireland where
people can have access to the goods from
the rest of the united kingdom uh that
they have every right to enjoy how are
you going to do it uh well negotiation
we're going to make sure that uh we're
not just going to rip up the deal no
we're going to talk to the eu but
nothing is off the table um one of the
things that the brexit process is
well
nothing is off the table
three things from the brexit negotiation
one
uh boris um in the past has proved
himself to be an expert negotiator and
has secured what he's needed when he's
needed it secondly part of that is being
prepared to say look if i don't get what
i want in this negotiation i am prepared
to walk away and to use alternative
methods and three
and three yeah you did do a deal in the
end and then three
always always always always always
always make sure that you have some
cards you keep close to your chest so
that you don't reveal your hand entirely
to the eye this is what schultz says he
says we have found a good way for
northern ireland and no one should
unilaterally i.e the uk override the
arrangement which we have agreed
together yes but one of the whole points
about the protocol and i know because i
was involved in making sure that the
protocol would work is that there's a
committee that's been set up to monitor
how it operates the whole reason we have
that committee is that the the protocol
as it was agreed contained lots of areas
with required further work that's why
we've got negotiations if that further
worked in negotiations uh can't yield
the results that we need then nothing is
off the table okay um the irish t-shirt
says he's worried about the peace
process should he rip up the deal and
the deputy
leader has also been talking about that
and he says we can't have any unilateral
action from the uk this is an
international agreement they have to
honor their obligation
well we do have obligations and we have
them under the good friday agreement the
belfast good friday agreement and what
we want to do is to make sure that in
northern ireland the executive the
government of northern ireland comes
together that means you need to get
people from both sinn fein and the dup
together at the moment the situation
with the protocol is a barrier to
getting the executive back together a
barrier it's a barrier to fulfilling the
agreement it's not the it's not the
european union's fault that the uk has
signed a bad deal as far as you're
concerned uh well it's going to lead to
trade wars which means a further
increase in the cost of living no um
well that's what the eu's saying well as
we've seen before in uh negotiations uh
there are some actors on one side of the
negotiation one side of the discussion
who will say certain things that's fine
i'm not going to criticize them but i
think the important thing is to
recognize that in uh boris and in list
trust we have two tough negotiators
boris and liz together secured not just
our deal and exit from the eu but a
number of free trade agreements that
people said that we couldn't sign in
that time so i you know full respect to
olive schultz and leo varadka but boris
and liz they are the negotiating duo
here we go
simon hall conservative chair of the
northern ireland select committee he
says no honorable country should act
unilaterally within an agreement
well uh simon uh i understand uh uh
knows a great deal about the protocol
because he's the chairman of the
northern ireland select committee as as
you say and he will know as i've said
that what we are seeking to do is to
negotiate and uh liz uh the foreign
secretary is seeing maharashtrikovich
the eu vice president
uh tomorrow will be keeping up at home
with all these names yes tomorrow that's
diplomacy um in order to make sure that
um uh we can take steps uh to resolve
this issue right so we are we are
talking uh that is what um you know
that's what foreign when will we see
whether you're either going to rip up
this agreement or not next week this
week months time uh there isn't any 23.
there isn't anything that's going to be
ripped up what we are doing is making
sure that we safeguard the position of
people um who are in northern ireland
within the united kingdom it is our
responsibility as the government of the
whole united kingdom to make sure that
people there have uh uh
are fully citizens of this country and
that the peace process is protected in
order to protect the peace process we
need to make sure that we get that
executive back up and running just
before i let you go um
how comfortable do you feel honestly
about the most law-breaking uh street in
london being where the prime minister
lives
i'm not sure what you mean 50 fixed
penalty notices so far more to come
probably for the prime minister as well
does that
sit happily with you
uh
this is a big issue it relates of course
to what went on in downing street and
indeed um more broadly that's the answer
it has to be said well i think that uh
i've been asked about this many times
and what i've i hope always said is
for anyone who um as so many people did
suffered during the pandemic it will be
difficult um to contemplate that uh laws
and rules were broken
i'm explaining exactly how i feel
because the question was a short and
pithy one
but it requires unpacking because there
is so much behind it but ultimately i
think that you have to judge these
things in the round um and uh my view is
that the prime minister and the people
who worked in number 10 downing street
um uh
uh contributed to getting the big
questions right in the pandemic um and
as recent figures show the united
kingdom even though the government was
roundly criticized the united kingdom
and it's not a race but the united
kingdom
uh did a better job collectively of
handling the covered uh pandemic than
many other countries and that is down to
the prime minister's leadership
we're out of time it's good to see you
thank you thank you very much thank you
thank you uh looking at the newspapers
for you this morning the guardian's
front page also looks at the queen's
speech and repeats the labour critique
the headline tori's bereft of ideas to
tackle cost of living crisis just heard
there from the leveling up secretary who
implicitly disagrees the daily mail says
a new law to make working from home easy
was axed from the speech the times has
details on proposals to allow councils
to tax the profit profits of developers
the daily telegraph reports that liz
trusts is standing firm in the face of
an eu trade war threat
and uh just remind while we've got you
actually that we'll be uh taking the
show on the road for a special series of
programmes next week going back to my
roots and uh finding out what the good
people of wigan feel about the cost of
living crisis do you let me know if
you'd like to get involved by sending me
a tweet you can use the hashtag
early and that's going to be here on sky
news at the usual time from the 16th of
may
still to come on the programme for you
this morning later this hour joined in
the studio by liberal democrat leaders
ed davey getting his reaction to
yesterday's queen's speech is the
government doing enough on the rising
cost of living
shadow secretary of state for justice
steve reed will be with us
uh just after eight actually and the
leader of the smp in westminster ian
blackburn will be with me later in the
programme lots to get into with him
following the queen's speech
[Music]
as experts warn inflation could go
higher than 10 percent in the coming
months is becoming ever more important
to seek out a bargain
shaman is standing by for us at a car
boot sale in south london hi good
morning tell us more about where you are
hi good morning yes so i'm at a car boot
sale in carl shelton and as you say as
the cost of living saws we could all do
with some extra cash in our pockets and
a car boot cell is a great way of doing
this many people come down here in fact
hundreds of people have been down here
this morning trying to find a good deal
as well as that it's a great way of
having a good old clear out and getting
some extra cash for those unwanted bits
and that's really necessary we know now
that every penny really does count and
it's been three separate reports out
this morning backing up those concerns
for example a survey by britain thinks
says that the cost of living is now a
dominant concern for many households and
that 90 percent of people are worried
about rising prices another the national
institute of economic and social
research said that 1.5 million people
that's one in 20 people face bills for
food and energy which they fear will
soon exceed their disposable income and
as well as that snowbrook bank said that
18 of people are losing sleep on this
issue in a quarter so that managing
their finances are their main concern of
stress now i've been down here at this
car boot sale speaking to people about
whether or not it's trickled down to
them i have spoken to a chap called
frank he buys and sells clothes down
here at the cole shelton boots car boot
cell and he says it's really had a huge
impact on the types of goods that people
are buying they're opting for children's
clothes and for school clothes and so on
rather than those nice dresses that they
may have worn for a night out so it's
definitely impacting the sales here at
carl shelton
okay lovely thank you
prime minister is traveling to finland
and sweden today as the two scandinavian
countries debate whether to join nato
with a decision expected this week boris
johnson will meet the leaders of both
nations to discuss security in europe
and also the war in the ukraine as
russian troops continue their pounding
the of the as of style steelworks in
mariopol a photojournalist has revealed
the grim extent of the suffering inside
in a series of stark pictures a
photographer with the press office of
the azov special forces regiment of the
ukrainian national guard has unveiled
the horror of the dimly lit makeshift
hospitals inside the plant the men are
seen with missing limbs bandaged with
makeshift linens and blooded clothes
others
are having deep cuts dressed behind
temporary plastic sheeting providing
barely any privacy
we're taking
heavy casualties we're taking losses
every day might be our last we have
extremely limited resources that are
very short
as for now
and
the result of this might be our imminent
death or capturing by the enemy which is
also means that for us
well deborah is danny bye for his in
kiev this morning um hello to you
deborah good morning to you when we see
images like those we've just been
sharing with our viewers it really
brings home the suffering in ukraine
doesn't it
it does in that situation the standoff
at the steel works has been one of the
most sort of iconic symbolic moments or
or images of ukraine's resistance to
russia's invasion these fighters in that
plant have been holding out since since
the beginning of the war like mariopol
which is the wider city uh was one of
the key first targets of russian forces
and while russia says they are in
control of the city they can't claim to
be in control of the whole of the city
because of those
those men
holding out in that plant and women too
fighters despite enduring horrendous
conditions limited access to food water
ammunition to be able to keep on
fighting and it's exactly this kind of
struggle that ukraine is enduring and
that's why other countries that have
until now had a neutral stance when it
comes to things like nato membership are
now thinking of joining i'm talking
primarily of course about sweden and
finland which is where the prime
minister is heading today both countries
have said that they are thinking about
potentially putting in an application to
join nato in the coming days and it
really underlines how russia's war in
ukraine has backfired spectacularly he
wanted to have less nato at his borders
supposedly and instead if these two
countries do decide that they are going
to join then he will have a lot more
thank you
amid all the suffering something that
those in ukraine may be able to
celebrate is their success at this
year's eurovision song
i wouldn't bet against them
orchestra has been voted through to the
grand final of the eurovision song
contest solidifying their position as
favorites in the competition
ukraine's folk rap track stefania has
been described by the group as a tribute
to the singer's mother but have since
dedicated to all the country's
matriarchs in the wake of the russian
invasion
do you recognize those two guys i bet
you did is elon musk saying that if he
succeeds in buying twitter he will
reinstate donald trump's account
in an interview with the financial times
the world's richest person said that
permanent bans should be extremely rare
the white press secretary responded at
the white house press secretary
responded saying social media platforms
must not become forums for
disinformation
banning trump from twitter didn't end
trump's voice
it will amplify it among the right and
this is why it is morally wrong and flat
out stupid
it's the decision by a private sector
company to make on who will or will not
be allowed on their platforms
what i will say broadly speaking is that
our effort is to of course make sure
that freedom of speech is protected
across the country but that also these
platforms are not used for format forums
for disinformation and we have seen a
history of that
not just on twitter but also on facebook
rebecca vardy has told the high court
she did not leak stories about colleen
rooney to the press as she gave evidence
in the wagatha christie libel trial for
the first time
she's suing rooney after being publicly
accused of leaking false stories to the
media in 2019 and after several months
of preliminary hearings the libel trial
got underway yesterday we'll be live at
the roll course of justice as the trial
continues later on this morning
before that though some of today's other
headlines flee and police have released
new footage showing the arrest of the
escaped alabama inmate casey white he's
surrendered to authorities but his
suspect
suspected accomplice a female prison
officer vicki white was found with
gunshot wounds and later died
the pair had stashed 29 000 pounds in
thousand dollars in cash four
semi-automatic handguns and an assault
rifle in the truck they took on the
nearly 300 miles from the prison in
alabama to indiana
at the time of the breakout mr white was
serving a 75-year prison term for
attempted murder and other offences and
was awaiting trial on charges of
stabbing a woman to death
the games company electronic arts says
it will stop making fifa branded games
next year it comes after fifa claims um
fifa was looking to double the fee it
charges for licensing to 1 billion the
series will continue under a new name
now could this be your lucky day camelot
says one lucky ticket holder in the uk
has won the jackpot of
184 million pounds don't forget the 262
899 pounds and 10 pence that makes
whoever holds that ticket the uk's
biggest ever national lottery winner
the legendary pop artist andy warhol's
1964 painting of marilyn monroe has sold
for a record
195 million dollars the silk screen
portrait named shot sage blue marilyn is
now the most expensive work ever sold at
auction by an american artist it's one
in a series of paintings of the actress
made by warhol following her death in
1962.
the head of the world health
organization has voiced concerns over
china's zero coveted policy it's a rare
public comment by the un agency on a
government's handling of the pandemic
we don't think that it's sustainable
considering the behavior of the virus
now and what we anticipate
in the future
and especially
when we have now
a good knowledge understanding of the
virus
tom standing by for us in beijing this
morning hi tom a very good morning to
you tell us more
morning i mean that word unsustainable i
want to show you what actually looks
like this is an apartment block in
beijing that's had a couple of covert
cases and it's been entirely sealed off
we'll take you a bit closer
and have a look now beijing is basically
under a lockdown right now schools are
shot gyms are shot restaurants are sharp
parks are sharp but they're not calling
it a lockdown they've had a handful of
cases 24 but these are the strict
measures that are taking place if you
look here they've been fencing up the
whole thing and the rest of us are free
to walk around but if you are caught
with the cobra case you're sent to a
centralized quarantine so dr tedros has
come up with this comment
saying it is unsustainable look at
what's happening in shanghai in
particular where they've had a very
strict lockdown for six weeks now
you can see all these guards outside
this place here making sure no one gets
out they're taking deliveries as well
they have been working really really
hard on this pandemic
and the question is whether really you
can keep doing that when we have
vaccines we'll get out there
um
these are called the big whites because
of their big white suits the pp and
there's lots of them all around beijig
the question is why is china sticking
with this and that reason is it hasn't
vaccinated enough of its elderly
population around 100
million people still haven't had a
vaccine and as a result they're sticking
with this covered zero the problem for
many people is wondering whether they
have a passcode vaccination because of
that covert zero policy they're spending
so much time as you can see
behind me enforcing that policy they're
not vaccinating people enough the rate
of vaccination has been dropping so
that's left a lot of people looking at
saying well look is this coveted zero as
a means to an end or is this an end in
itself this sort of control is this new
normal for china
okay thanks a lot thank you fascinating
stuff thank you
um let's tell you about the podcaster
deborah james she says she's mind blown
by the outpouring of support she's
received after raising more than two
million pounds for charity
and that was in a very very short period
of time having set up the funding appeal
on monday
miss james told her instagram followers
that she was moving to hospice at home
care to treat her terminal bowel cancer
after developing the illness in 2016 ms
james has dedicated her life to raising
money for charitable causes
this is a live update of deborah's just
giving page there you go or in fact more
than two and a quarter
million pounds
some of the items in this morning's
papers are guaranteed to raise some
pulses the times pictures are later
practicing yoga
for a book um
i don't think we should have that advert
on there should we let's take that off
should we let's have a look at this one
instead should we uh it's another
picture for extreme lakeland uh there
you go in the telegraph a wonderful feat
of photography a brave base jumper
diving 600 feet into chilly waters in
the lake district
and don't look down walkers step out on
the world's longest suspension bridge
stretching and astonishing
2
365 feet very impressive
other news for you now
and
have you had
your morning coffee i don't actually
like coffee but there we go a new study
has found drinking espressos could cause
higher cholesterol levels in men but not
in women academics from norway found
that people who drank three to five
espressos a day were more likely to have
higher levels of cholesterol in the
blood compared with those who did not
drink espresso and the level of
cholesterol were higher in men than they
were in women so there
now amid the continuing unrest in sri
lanka speaking to a resident there about
the situation on the ground
[Music]
leveling up secretary michael gove has
told this program there will be not be i
should say there will not be an
emergency budget however he said the
government was exploring how it could
help those struggling with the rising
cost of living let's take a listen back
to what he had to say
we heard from the prime minister
yesterday saying he will um say more in
the days to come on how to help people
with the cost of living and then almost
immediately the treasury is saying
there'll be no emergency budget and
we'll set out the budget timetable in
the usual way so who's right is it is it
going to be an emergency budget or not
um uh they're both right and no there
won't be an emergency budget okay
explain that to me i will um the the key
thing is um it's sometimes the case it
would never happen with sky it's
sometimes the case the words from a
prime minister or a minister are
over-interpreted so the prime minister
is right we will be saying more and
doing more in order to help people with
the cost of living a challenge that we
face at the moment but that doesn't
amount to an emergency budget it is part
of the work of government
turkey this morning wasn't he he was yes
and i think you know the big question
yesterday at the end of all of this was
is there enough on the cost of living
because the government were talking a
lot about growth in that queen's speech
they were talking about growing the
economy but that is obviously you know a
more long-term thing i think the
question is in the short term what's
going to be done and i think you could
tell that the prime minister was under
pressure because in the house of commons
he said that we he said that him and the
chancellor would go further in the
coming days so that was really
interesting um but then we had the
chancellor later suggesting there's
gonna be no emergency budget you asked
michael go rightly about that he um
slightly sort of dodged the question you
heard him there saying they're both
right and no there won't be an emergency
budget um we will be saying and doing
more um he said that journalists
sometimes over-interpret things but i
don't think that was a particularly
clear answer from michael and no we're
going to be talking about partygate as
well it's interesting what he had to say
about that i think we'll discuss it at
eight o'clock eight o'clock look forward
to it thanks very much indeed ellie
thank you
meantime the prime minister is visiting
sweden and finland today to discuss the
war in ukraine as the two nordic
countries debate whether to join nato
joining us now is the former director of
policy planning at nato that's fabri
pothie hello to you thank you so much
for joining us on the program this
morning uh what what's your view what do
you think um will happen uh with these
two countries and and nato's reaction
i i think the train has already long
left the station as to whether those two
countries will be joining
nato so it's just now a question of
technicality
of uh getting the the right legal and
obviously security arrangements but my
best from the start from the 24th of
february onwards was that those two
countries would be sitting at the uh
nato table with the other heads of
states in madrid at the end of june
um
how do you think vladimir putin might
interpret what's going on
well we will all hope that he will
interpret that as a another uh proof
that his strategy is actually backfiring
both in ukraine but also in the broader
europe uh he might indeed intend
on putting pressure on those two
countries i mean pressure has been on
those two countries from russia since
2014 2015. since essentially they got
closer to nato
that there should not be the capacity to
defend themselves and the fact that the
uk the us and other nato countries uh uh
uh covering their back should not be
underestimated so i think we are now
really entering a a historic moment
where we are closing one of the big
remaining gaps in the baltic region in
terms of nato membership
i did speak to a member of the duma um
earlier on in the week and they were
saying
that if this did happen then um finland
particularly would then be allowed to
have nato weapons on its soil and as a
result russia would see that as a threat
well i think russia likes to see
everything it wants to see as a threat
to justify the kind of war of aggression
they have unleashed on on ukraine so i
don't think this statement should be
taken literally
as to whether nato forces and weapons
would be deployed on those countries uh
territory i think this is their decision
and the nato decision but for the moment
what you see is that finland is very
much capable of defending itself it has
one of the largest land forts in europe
it's really going to boost
nato's defensive capabilities in the
baltic but across the airline so i would
not worry about deploying something on
those uh territories yet
but it's a big change for finland itself
isn't it particu particularly the
defense policy previously had been
considered to be
neutral and militarily that would change
now
neutral but not incapable
i think that's a very important
distinction i mean this is one of the
countries that has purchased f 35 the
last generation fighter jet from the
united states so they are part of the ff
35 club uh again a very large research
force
so neutrality doesn't mean not
the lack of capacity of defending itself
i think the real change is more in
sweden
where until and still now there is this
ideological kind of link with this
notion of non-alignment which is not
entirely true because sweden is part of
the eu
and has also taken side in some crisis
but i think sweden is more struggling
with its own ideological background here
how long does this process take for them
to join nato what's considered
as long as the uh uh
the kind of membership documents if you
want are ratified in each nato uh
parliament
including the u.s congress
and this is why there's this kind of
in-between moment between the
declaration of membership and and the
full fledged legal membership
where my understanding is some of the
big nato countries the us but also the
uk will be providing bilateral security
guarantees so that there is no ambiguity
that those countries are going to be
vulnerable to some sort of
russian pressure
okay great to talk to you thank you
thank you very much
in other news protesters in sri lanka
are calling for a new government after
eight people were killed in deadly
clashes as the country faces its worst
economic
crisis since gaining independence
sandon fernando is in the capital of
which is columba of course for us this
morning hello to you thank you for
joining us what is the latest situation
there
hi uh good morning uh and after the
defender mr uh given permission to try
forces to
open fire at anyone who is looting or
anyone behaving on manner the situation
is getting peaceful right now so behind
me you can see this is a lot radiant
made into the president's private
residences so they are not allowing to
enter anyone who doesn't have a any sort
of uh official identification or
official reason so i had a chance to
speak with the several people around
this area around the colombo so they
said with the cursive situation they are
having very hard time because they are
not getting enough essential supply so
today morning uh the full drivers who is
transporting fuel they say they will
withdraw from their transportation
service
and uh because we don't have a full
coming to the people right now and
political situation also getting uh very
pressurable to resign the president
today morning the two opposition
okay it's good to talk to you thank you
so much for your insight much
appreciated thank you
well joining us now is a resident in
colombo that's nisley hameem hello to
you thank you for joining us on the
programme what is life like for you
at the moment in colombo
it was uh
what we were doing was a peaceful
protest
but the pro government and the german
people try to attack us so that's where
everything went wrong and people are
suffering people who are suffering for
the last
two years or so it's been
because of the mismanagement
of the government especially because of
the rajpakshas
so people's demands are very clear just
leave us and
take accountability for what you have
done
we've been going through
like a lot of [ __ ] uh even to get a pump
to your car you need to be in the line
for like six to eight hours there is no
meal powder no
gas for cooking all the like small
businesses are getting clothes
including no medicines for children no
medicine for the elderly
so
it's like i love these countries like
this country is
like we are fighting for this country
but
at the moment because of these
politicians action this country has
turned into a hellhole and we are
suffering from it yes
okay thank you very much indeed for
joining us thank you and thread davey
leader of the lib dems is with us in the
studio you and you were just saying that
you follow the situation in sri lanka
very closely
yeah there's a lot of people who've uh
refugees from sri lanka particularly
tamil community
and i represent all of tamil uh british
tamils
and they have always been pretty angry
by the government there the rajapaksa
family who got the president and the
prime minister
and uh frankly have run the whole
economy in a very corrupt way
and have mismanaged the economy and now
it's affecting the lives of of everybody
in sri lanka
so um i hope our government will be
sending the strongest signals to tell
the rajapakse government it's time for
them to go
what
intel did you get from the queen's
speech yesterday when it comes to our
government's view on our own cost of
living crisis
not a lot i mean i was hugely
disappointed as i was expecting
that after
the people had said during the local
election results they were not happy the
government would take some action um but
there was nothing for the cost of living
and there are millions of facts what do
you want them to do
there's no money
there is we need a vat tax cut that's
what liberal democrats have argued for
we're 600 pounds and you can pay for
that by asking the oil and gas companies
to to pay windfall tax they're making
huge profits and that's the flip side of
those higher uh heating bills and the
higher prices that the the petrol pumps
the government minister on the program
earlier in the week said they're paying
enough tax for now
well um i disagree with him um i want a
fair tax i'm on a fair society i want to
help people
and when a company needs these oil and
gas companies are making profits they
never expect to make this a huge super
profit
it's only fair to ask them to pay the
money to help people who are having to
pay those bills it was really
interesting one of the chief executives
of these companies said the other day
that their investment plans would not be
affected at all by a windfall tax which
is the government's previous argument
they're using against it and so the
government have got nowhere to hide now
they should ask these oil and gas
companies to pay more money and then we
have that money for the tax cut that
millions of families and pensioners need
how worried are you about the northern
ireland protocol being ripped up we had
mr gove on the program just a few
moments ago and he was based he said it
was never set in stone it was something
that was always fluid and and was meant
to be negotiated along the way
well i have to say i disagree with uh mr
goh it was an international treaty
international treaties aren't settings
uh are aren't fluid and flexible they're
they're clearly treaties what worries me
about this is the government seemed to
be prepared to contemplate a trade war
with our european
neighbours a trade war a time of a cost
of living emergency would be an absolute
disaster people need to be aware that if
the government go down that route
the inflation we've seen so far will get
even worse
the supplies of things in the shops
would get even worse
and you know the government needs to be
helping people people are really
struggling
and for michael gove and boris johnson
and the rest of them to think that a a
trade war is the right way to deal with
a cost living crisis and economic crisis
i don't know what planet they're living
on well interestingly i did put that to
him and he said that that would just not
happen that it's there's not going to be
a trade war well i i sincerely hope
there isn't but if they're thinking of
ditching the the protocol which was the
international treaty let's remember that
boris johnson signed it was his idea
if they now turn their back on that um
the danger is there would be a trade war
i mean let's be realistic about this and
and i really worry about that i worry
about that for the people of northern
ireland for the business of northern
ireland and i worry about it for the for
people across united kingdom people are
already
hurting enough uh they're really
suffering they're worried about the
increase in uh heating and energy bills
that's going to come this autumn they're
worried about the higher taxes they're
paying
for the conservatives now to say well
it's okay there'll be a trade war i'm
sorry that's just not acceptable
you talk about energy uh costs uh i also
put it to mr gove that before brexit he
did say that that would be cut on energy
bills um that hasn't happened
he's now said that that is because it
would be a five percent cut for
everybody and dukes and princes don't
need that cut
well um uh
the problem with mr gove and the
conservatives is they keep breaking
their promises
uh this is not the only promise they've
broken they promised not to raise taxes
and they've risen they've put up taxes
they promised not pensioners that they
would keep the triple lock on pensions
they've broken that promise this is a
government that breaks promises left
right and center and it's hurting people
out there but do you think a cut on the
vat on energy bills is the right way
forward i think a broader cut in vat is
the right way forward i wouldn't just
limit to energy bills food prices are
going up petrol prices are going up the
way to really help people in a very big
and bold way is what liberal democrats
are arguing for which is a two and a
half percent cut in vat down to
seventeen and a half percent uh that
would give the average family 600 pounds
uh a year so i think that's the sort of
bold measure that's needed you can only
be enough there is it for energy bills
600 quid well it would go some way i
mean we have a another set of policies
linked to that which would help the most
vulnerable because 600 pounds would be
for everybody uh for the average family
um but there are pensioners disabled
people people on very low incomes who
will need some extra help so we've
argued that what's called a warm home
discount which takes money directly off
people's energy bills that that should
be doubled and the number of people who
could get that would be should be
increased so that's real help to people
who are struggling where are you on
secure stammer and um beer gate
well um at the weekend
i was suggesting that
he would have to consider a position if
he got a fixed penalty notice he would
he would have to um and then
earlier this week he actually said
that's what he position he would take
that if he got a
fixed penalty notice from the durham
police he would resign
and i was actually
quite pleased to see him say that
because i think that shows
integrity and willingness to to accept
the consequences and i just wish that
the prime minister showed some integrity
yeah but in march he did say i think it
was in march and the leader of the
opposition said because the prime
minister was being investigated by the
police he should resign and now he's
being investigated by the police but
he's not resigning
well uh listen he's got to make his own
decision right right well he
i've said that i think it's at least
good that he's said he's prepared to
resign if he gets a fixed penalty notice
uh i just know the prime minister's had
a fixed penalty notice he's not resigned
i also note there's a possibility that
the prime minister might get even more
fixed penalty notices so the prime
minister's in charge of our country he's
supposed to be helping people
uh who are struggling he's not doing
that and my worry is he's he's not
giving leadership he's now become a very
weak leader because he's dogged by this
these crisis we're almost out of time
but my question is um should the leader
of the opposition who is now uh part of
a criminal investigation resigned given
that that's what he said the prime
minister should do well um uh i i
haven't said that uh i've been really
clear of my position uh throughout this
he he
he he's got to decide he's his own uh
position i actually called on the prime
minister to resign not when there's a
police investigation i called for him to
resign before that and i explained why
he had said he he
he lied to parliament about parties and
it turned out with allegra stratton's uh
comments that there were parties so my
uh problem with the prime minister it's
not just that he broke the law but he's
dishonest okay it's good to see you sure
thank you for joining us on the program
this morning thank you what does michael
gove think about the criminality at
number 10 downing street not to come in
just a moment here on sky stay tuned
[Music]